let's see what if we can figure out what
x
plus 3
times
x
minus 3 is and i encourage you to pause
the video and see if you can work this
out
well one way to tackle it is the way
that we've always tackled when we
multiply binomials is just apply the
distributive property twice
so first we could take this entire
yellow x plus three and multiply it
times each of these two terms so first
we can multiply it times this x so
that's going to be x times
x plus 3.
and then we are going to
multiply it times we could say this is
negative 3.
so we could write minus 3 times now
that's going to be multiplied by
x plus 3 again
x plus 3 and then we apply the
distributive property one more time
where we take this magenta x and we
distribute it across this x plus 3 so x
times x is x squared x times 3 is 3x
and then we do it
on this side negative 3
times x is negative 3x and negative 3
times 3
is negative 9.
and what does this simplify to well
we're going to get x squared and we have
3x minus 3x so these two characters
cancel out and we are just left with x
squared
minus nine
and you might see a little pattern here
notice i added three and then i
subtracted three and i got this i got
the x
squared and then if you take three and
multiply it by negative three you're
going to get a negative 9. and notice
the middle terms canceled out and one
thing you might ask is well will that
always be the case if we add a number
and then we subtract that same number
like that and we could try it out let's
let's talk in general terms so if we
instead of doing x plus 3 times x minus
3 we could write the same thing as
instead of 3 let's just say you have x
plus
x plus a
times x minus a
times x minus a and i encourage you to
pause this video and work it all out
just assume a is some number like 3 or
some other number and apply the
distributive property twice and see what
you get
let's work through it so first we can
distribute this yellow x plus a
onto the x and the negative a so x plus
a times x or we could say x times x plus
a so it's going to be
that's going to be
x
times
x plus a and then
we're going to have
minus a or this negative a times x plus
a so minus
then we're going to have this minus a
times x plus a
times
x
plus a
times x plus a notice all i did is i
distributed this yellow this i just
distributed this big chunk of this
expression i just distribute it onto the
x and onto this negative a i'm
multiplying it times the x and i'm
multiplying it by the negative a
and now we can apply the distributive
property again
x times x is x squared
x times a is
ax
and then we get
negative a times x is negative ax and
then negative a times a is negative
a squared and notice regardless of my
choice of a i'm going to have ax and
then minus ax so this is always going to
cancel out it didn't just work for the
case when a was 3 for any a if i have a
times x and then i subtract a times x
that's just going to cancel out
so this is just going to cancel out and
what are we going to be left with we are
going to be left with
x squared
minus a squared
minus a squared and you could view this
as a special case when you have
something x plus something times x minus
that same something it's going to be x
squared minus that something squared and
this is a good one to know in general
and we could use it to quickly figure
out the products of other binomials that
fit this pattern here so if i were to
say quick
what is
x
plus 10 times x
minus 10.
well you could say all right this is
just going this fits the pattern it's x
plus a times x minus a so it's going to
be x squared minus a squared if a is 10
if a is 10 a squared is going to be 100.
so you can do it really quick once you
recognize the pattern